residents in a northwest neighborhood
are really fired up over the thought of
a 5g cell tower coming to their
neighborhood in fact the tower is
supposed to be built in a homeowner's
backyard near campbell and west washburn
road victoria saha spoke to some
residents just ahead of that planned
meeting on the issue
[Music]
many residents in this lone mountain
area are frustrated over the thought of
a possible cell tower coming to their
neighborhood some even woke up to this
document in their mailbox asking them to
come to the tuesday planning commission
meeting to voice their concerns
this neighborhood in the northwest part
of the valley is tucked away from the
hustle and bustle of las vegas the sound
of nature is what drove troy wayne to
this area 12 years ago the world
preservation
area out here it kind of protects us but
now he's fearful the rural lifestyle he
loves will be disrupted after a company
called intellisites wants to build a 5g
cell tower in his neighbor's yard
similar to this we're going to see a big
tower with fake tree limbs hanging off
of it
you know and from what i've read you
know
it has an adverse react
effect on a on wildlife randy anderson
will be able to see it right from his
backyard right behind these palm trees
is where you would see it right on the
other side of this uh wall the tower
would be twice as close to my house as
it would be to their house
so
i don't think it belongs there i don't
want it
and
i vote no we went over to the property
where the cell tower would be placed the
property owner would not talk to us on
camera but says they're in contract with
the company and cannot back out they
also say if plans move forward they
would get an average of 4 thousand
dollars a month why
should they
profit
off of something
that is affecting everyone else i did
reach out to the county they say that
the planning commission could have a
decision by the end of their meeting but
depending on whatever they decide the
residents here are still allowed to
appeal it victoria saha live local now